the jogan experience do you know the one
one of the dudes that survived the
Titanic he was in the water for two
hours I think he was a chef and the
story was that he got drunk before he
went in the water he just got hammered
because he knew he was going to die and
somehow or another because he was drunk
he survived see if you can find that got
it I was reading this I was like how
does that makes sense how a baker
survive the Titanic sinking by getting
really drunk Dam blockers these
[__] there we go okay so can
you go back up so I could read scoll so
it says Charles how do you say that joen
how do you say that
Jamie johen join was one of the
disaster's most unlikely survivors and
he did it thanks to Industrial amounts
of liquor so this dude got super duper
hammered before he went in the water and
somehow or another it helped him
survive uh it was an almost
physiologically impossible feat of
survival and according to the British
Titanic inquiry is because the
33-year-old Englishman had the presence
of mind to greet History's Greatest
Maritime Disaster by getting
smashed so he knew he was dying he knew
he was dying so he just decided to get
[__] up but he survived uh in survival
situations having all that warm blood
away from the vital organs means that
the Drinker at a greater risk of
hypothermia however Canadian hypothermia
expert
Gordon
GB figures in the min-2 de C temperature
of the North Atlantic the water was cold
enough to quickly tighten joen blood
vessels and cancel out any effects of
the
alcohol so then at a low to moderate
doses of alcohol cold will win out says
uh G BR a University of Manitoba
professor has performed hundreds of cold
water immersion studies what yohen would
have had however is the awesome
life-saving power of liquid courage
alcohol remains a leading cause of
humans getting into fatal situations
including freezing to Deaths
nevertheless the relaxing qualities of
the drug have long been known to give
humans an uncanny ability to survive
trauma this reminded me of the story the
lady that passed out in the in the snow
and her friends found her like the next
day and they brought her in she was
still alive yeah they're saying right
here in the ER cold patients who are
really drunk can walk in and they're
conscious at a temperature that we that
they shouldn't
be so did being drunk keeps you alive
keep scrolling down a little more that's
it that's it no no no yeah um his
actions might speak to a man unfazed by
impending disaster immediately upon
hearing the collision with an iceberg
the chief Baker leapt out of his bunk
and began dispatching his staff to stock
the lifeboats with bread and biscuits
this done he popped back into his cabin
for a drink before heading topside to
help load lifeboats not not only did
walking what how what however I say his
name joking refus his own place on a
boat but he and there's no men like that
today but he and a few other men became
forcibly chuckling chucking reluctant
women into empty seats likely saving
their lives he said we threw them in he
testified later top deck of the
increasingly listing Titanic was mostly
cleared of lifeboats by 1:30 a.m. to
most this was a panic inducing sign that
all hopes of rescue was gone but to uh
whatever his name is it was a CU to head
back to his cabin for another drink so
this dude's just getting [__] up he
sat down on his bunk and nursed it along
aware but not particularly caring that
the water now rippled through the cabin
doorway wrote historian uh Walter Lord
in a night to remember Lord was in touch
with the dude uh before the baker's 1956
death he said the dude then uh splashed
top side again where he took upon
himself to begin throwing deck chairs
overboard with an eye to filling the
water with impromptu flotation
devices so the people could float around
on the chairs his perched he then worked
his way back to the pantry to get a
drink of water the baker was standing on
the stern when the ship broke in half
and yet he remembered the violent
catastrophic breakup only as a great
list over to Port there was no great
shock or anything he told the inquir so
he was just
hammered definitely moving through the
Swarms of people he made it to the stern
rail of the ship exactly 2:20 a.m. he
rode the sinking Titanic into the sea
like an
elevator
woo as with all surviving Titanic crew
members 2:20 a.m. on April 15th 1912 was
also the exact moment at which the White
Star Line stopped paying him oh boy the
first stage of cold water immersion is
known as cold shock horrifying sensation
to having the skin cool the feelings
with the Titanic Second Officer Charles
light Towler uh described as being like
a thousand knives being driven into
one's
body so this how did this dude survive
what did he float around on for two
hours does it
say paddling and Treading Water you said
I was just paddling and treading water
for two
hours oh my
God how come couldn't do that then in
the movie Just sunk in the water after
two minutes but this Leo wasn't hammered
and he gave up this dude didn't give up
he paddled water for hours I guess it
took a couple hours for them to get
someone to get to them yeah he after two
hours which is pretty impressive that
they got to them in two hours eventually
hold in 19 what what was this like 19 or
somewhere around there I don't know the
exact 1912 some I don't know the early
1900s so the fact they got to them in 2
hours is pretty May 1919
2019 oh no
107th yeah okay so 12 yeah 1912
wow